-I'm sorry I slept
with your agent.
-Sorry that --
-And your manager.
And your divorce lawyer.
-Yeah.
-Uh, I'm sorry I gave up on us.
-Why is it always so hard?
-[ Sighs ]
I think 'cause you're so strong.
You're so intimidating.
You're so talented.
-Hmm.
I feel like nobody would be able
to fix the script the way you do
and stay
in such incredible shape.
-And you are an amazing mother.
-[ Sighs ]
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Leslie Mann.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a clip from
"The Bubble."
-Yes.
-So, very COVID-inspired film
about making a film --
an action film with special
effects during COVID.
So, you have a cast full of
actors, you have a director,
all staying in a luxury hotel
together.
-Mm-Hmm.
-It also seems like it would be
fun to make
because that was basically what
you were doing...
-What was happening, yeah.
-...as well, in real life, too.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, it was.
-And David Duchovny plays
your co-star in the film,
who is also your ex-husband, to
give some context to the clip.
And David Duchovny is a lot
of fun to be around.
-David Duchovny is a lot of fun
to be around, yes.
[ Laughter ]
He is. I mean, he's --
I've actually known him --
well, I met him,
like, 27 years ago, on
my first job, called "Birdland."
And he was working on
"The X-Files."
And, um, we met, and I think
he was, like, into me.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And we -- you know,
he invited me to his set,
and then I invited him
to my hotel room
for a Halloween party.
And then my best friend
and I and David,
with the three of us, were going
to a bar after the party.
And we got into a cab,
started to leave,
and David stopped the cab,
and he got out of the cab
and left the cab.
-Okay.
-Ran away from the cab.
And then didn't speak to me
again for 27 years.
-Really?
-Yes.
-Wow!
-I know.
-Did you find out
what you had done?
-So, we talked about it a lot
over the course of 27 years.
Like, "What happened?
What is this?"
And then when we, you know, met
again, or were about to have
this reunion on "The Bubble,"
I like, worked up the courage
to go and ask him,
"What the hell happened?"
Like, "Why did you get out of
the cab?"
And he said, um, "Oh, yeah,
I kind of remember that.
I think I just left my weed
in my room."
[ Laughter ]
And that was it.
-Yeah.
-27 years, you're beating
yourself up --
-Tortured.
-Just because David Duchovny
can't remember his weed
before a party.
-Exactly, I know.
-It's very kind that
you forgave him for that.
-Right? Don't do drugs.
[ Laughter ]
-Unless you can meet God.
So, you --
there's some roller skating.
You're on roller skates
in this film.
-I am.
-You seem like you know
what you're doing.
Is this something you learned
from the film?
-Yeah.
I mean, we all roller skated
when we were kids, right?
And then we give it up.
Like, we give up roller skating
and skateboarding
'cause it's just weird to do
that as an adult, right?
-Yeah, and there's just too high
a risk -- the reward --
-It's high-Risk, right.
-The reward is not good enough
for the risk.
-Right, right, right.
So I picked it up again,
like, a couple of years ago --
a year and a half ago,
during lockdown --
and it was just, like,
a good exercise and, like,
a good outlet, you know, for all
of my pent-up energy.
[ Laughs ]
-Were you roller skating, like,
in the neighborhood?
-No, I had, like, a little space
this big,
and I would just sit in front
of a mirror and like --
And just go.
And I would watch --
-You're doing fine
as an empty-nester.
[ Laughter ]
Don't let anybody tell you
you're not thriving.
What with your little at-home
roller skate rink.
[ Laughter ]
-It's so bad.
It's really bad.
-Well, at least you're not
talking to cats.
Oh, wait.
-Oh, wait.
[ Laughter ]
-Maude gave you her cats?
-Maude -- okay, so, we have
two cats, Honey and Pumpkin.
And then Maude got
two more cats,
Chris, named after Christopher
from "The Sopranos," and Dolly,
and then she dropped them off
at our house
and never picked them up.
So now we have four cats,
and I spend a lot of time
with the cats.
[ Laughter ]
And so, yeah, you know,
the kids notice
that I'm having, like, very long
conversations now with the cats.
And it's gotten a little weird,
but they're great cats.
They're not, like,
your average cat.
They're, like, smart and fun.
-They're, like, good listeners.
-They're good listeners.
They are. They're great.
-So, you have a video
of your cat.
Is this --
Who made the video for you?
-What? Well Honey
made the video.
-Oh, your cat made the video?
So this would be proof that
this is not your normal cat.
Let's take a look at Honey
real quick.
-Of course, Leslie and I talk,
Seth.
We're both fascinating people
with a lot to say.
What do you expect?
Don't listen to the haters,
babe.
I'm sick of dog people giving us
a hard time.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you sure you didn't do
ayahuasca?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God!
See?
They're not like
your average cats. [ Laughs ]
-I'm so happy you're here.
By the way, Judd's gonna be here
tomorrow.
He wrote a new book.
Have you read it?
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That's very --
-It's good, yeah.
This is a good book.
It's about -- he's really into,
like, cartoons since he was
a kid, and -- yeah, it's, um --
-You're looking at it like
you're hoping to get information
from the cover.
[ Laughter ]
That's great. That's great.
-Yeah, okay.
-Thank you.
What a great --
What a great sales pitch.
-Leslie Mann, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"The Bubble" is streaming now
on Netflix.